welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the real star of the marvel
announcements on disney plus day was
hulk's arm after last scene cooked in
slung in avengers end game and then
still slung when bruce banner reverted
to human form in the post-credits scene
of chongqi it now appears fully healed
with bruce back in his smart hulk form
in the she-hulk teaser leaving many
obsessed watchers on social media with
questions about she-hulk's timeline
hulk's healing abilities and how unsafe
it is to walk around in a gamma lab
barefoot like if she-hulk can wear
customized cross trainers so can you
bruce and now that shangshi is out on
disney plus with an expanded imax aspect
ratio revealing more visual details on
bruce's arm we can actually deduce some
answers for bruce banner's mysterious
whereabouts and why this is the case so
in avengers inn game smart hulk stepped
up to snap the six stones in the start
gauntlet to bring back the dusted
explaining that his gamma-radiated body
made him compatible with the stone's
cosmic radiation but the radiation's
mostly gamma
it's like
i was made for this he actually told him
earlier that he achieved his current
fuse status yeah a pretty vague summary
of some experiments he had been doing 18
months in a gamma lab i put the brains
and the bra together and now look at me
best of both worlds now by the way this
scene was actually a reconceived version
of smart hulk's introduction in avengers
end game based off of earlier versions
of the movie which would have shown
banner in that form-fitting top saving
people from a burning building we also
saw deleted scenes in concept art from
infinity wars final act that would have
actually shown smart hulk bursting out
of that hulkbuster armor earlier in this
movie as well as chatting with natasha
in sam and then there was some
interesting end game previz footage that
would have shown hulk trying to type his
stupid sausage fingers into a keyboard
in a lab which in the background
contains iron man suits but does look a
bit like the gamma lab where we now see
them in she-hull in in-game banners
snapping the stones cooked his arm and
his shoulder leaving him injured for the
final battle and putting his arm in a
sling for tony stark's funeral and in
the final scene in which he sends steve
rogers back down the quantum tunnel and
then in the shanghai post credits scene
banner appears again but back in human
form but arm's still in a sling from
which we inferred that banner must have
de-hulked but that maybe the stone
radiation was so damaging that his arm
was still in the healing process and
then we all assume that this human form
mystery would have something to do with
shield but then now in this she-hulk
teaser he's back in smart hulk form his
arm fully healed though even as a bit of
a continuity whiplash
are we looking at a gap in mcu
continuity the marvel studios just make
a mistake no
impossible
one explanation many of you have asked
me about is that maybe this particular
scene in she-hulk could be taking place
before the main in-game event like after
banner's 18 months in the game of lab
sometime during the years of the blip
this explanation would set jennifer
walter's transformation into she-hulk
during the blip before banner's big
green arm was burned now i do see the
logic of that but i just doubt that will
be the case because suggesting that
jennifer walters already had her powers
during the final battle of endgame would
just pose too many questions about where
she was during those events why she
didn't help now yes you could argue that
marvel has done flashbacks the blip era
before like one division similarly
flashback to monica rambo's moments
right as the blip ended but in general
marvel definitely seems to be looking
forward focusing on endgame's aftermath
and setting new superhero transformation
moments in the present why well they
want to keep the focus on the hero and
avoid the setting overshadowing the
character like think about it the blip
was a crazy post-apocalyptic period of
time somewhere between the leftovers and
mad max one that i hope the mcu explores
in future titles but setting jen
walter's crucial transformation moment
into she-hulk in the middle of the blip
might make this story more of a blip
series than a she-hulk series just take
it from an mcu timeline nerd who has
been burned too many times for sweating
these kind of details marvel loves to
include easter eggs to reward fans and
reference other titles to set stuff up
sometimes to conceal plot twists and
promo footage but they almost never
spend vfx money like this to make things
needlessly complicated and paint
themselves into continuity quarters like
they would be doing here if they said
this was taking place before end game
too many questions really folks in this
case i think hulk's arm and his hulk to
human back to hulk transition tells us a
far more straightforward and in my
opinion more interesting story about his
healing process and how that process
relates to she-hulk's origin part of
doing this job is you have to look at
everything closely and listen everything
closely and listen to things closely
gotta have good headphones and earbuds
and when i'm doing anything on the go
walking my dog working out
walking my dog i like to listen to
podcasts with my raycon earbuds and
thanks to raycon for sponsoring this
video so like you know when you're
walking the dog when you're reaching out
to scoop stuff up the last thing you
want is for your earbuds to fall out
well these new everyday earbuds have
optimized gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit
[Music]
i love you so much i love you so much
oh and i can still hear my podcasts
these new models have an improved rubber
oil look and feel really sturdy raycons
offer 8 hours of play time and a 32 hour
battery life that's way longer than any
dog walk i will ever go on there's also
a built-in mic so that you can take
calls with the press of a button raycons
start at half the price of other premium
audio brands but they sound just as good
and they come with a 45-day happiness
guarantee these are an everyday
necessity whether i'm exercising or
running errands i just know that raycons
are gonna sound great they fit great and
they look great so click the link in the
description box or go to buy raycon.com
new rockstars to unlock exclusive deals
of up to 20 off your reikon order and
thanks again to raycon for sponsoring
this episode see sheng chi on disney
plus reveals more details and an
expanded imax aspect ratio that many of
us couldn't see in the theatrical cut
and that includes the post-credits scene
and the framing of bruce banner in his
sling seeing it now closely you could
tell that while his arm is in the sling
the burn scarring that were on his arm
at the end of end game have now nearly
completely healed he's like 98 healed at
this point also banner's hair is longer
and grayer than it was the last time we
saw him in human form suggesting that
quite some time has passed to the
present mcu where i think chongqi and
where i think she-hulk are taking place
but then on banner's left arm is some
piece of tech attached to his wrist with
a glowing green light i'm wondering if
this could be a kind of restraint that
temporarily keeps him in human form
while he heals it could just be that
banner was unable to treat the scarring
the cosmic radiation seared into his
green hulk flesh and was forced to
temporarily revert to his human form in
order to treat it maybe even something
the sorcerers could have helped out with
since we know banner was in touch with
wong but like the ancient one they
needed him to be in his grounded ruffalo
state in order to deal with him but more
importantly it is worth remembering the
origin of jennifer walters she-hulk in
the comics by a transfusion of bruce
banner's blood if she-hulk the series
were to stick to that origin story
banner probably needed to be in human
form to be able to give her that
transfusion because think about it no
needle would be able to penetrate his
green skin so that would give us another
and probably better reason for banner to
revert to his human form to give a
life-saving transfusion to his cousin
and then when his game irradiated blood
causes jennifer to chaotically hulk out
the she-hulk series would show bruce
banner returning to a smart hulk form in
order to show his cousin that a balanced
stasis that maintains your intellect can
be reached but jennifer and we would
need to see that transition from human
to hulk in order to learn how to do that
kevin feige himself hinted in an
interview with screen rant in september
that hulk's mysterious healing process
and his human form in chiang chi were
not an oversight but would actually be
linked to she-hulk's origin you know
captain marvel and young banner there
but he's banner not hulk not smart hulk
so
he's banner his arm's in a sling if you
notice that why did why is he back to
being in like a human form and
does this have anything to do with his
future she-hulk anything like that all
good questions sir all very good
very obs a very observant
uh questions you will find out why that
is the case yes this tells us that
banner being a human in chiang chi was
not a mistake but rather an intentional
step in marvel's plan to bring she-hulk
into the mcu he wouldn't need to be a
human in shanghai if the healed arm in
she-hulk meant that the plan for the
scene was for it to be a blip flashback
no i think we're gonna see that healing
process finalized and it's gonna connect
medically to his cousin getting her
powers and both bruce and jen will hold
up together like peter b parker teaching
miles morales how to switch except now
instead of whip to a flip it's going to
be drip rip because there's no way
hoodie stretched that part hey to
support this channel you can check out
one of our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
or breakdowns and analysis of everything
marvel thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you